>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Jon Voss: Well welcome to Between
Two Friends with Smithsonian Library
of Congress and National Archives
where we ask irreverent questions
of some of the most powerful
people in cultural heritage.
So thank you.
This is going to be.
Hey come on guys, this
is going to be good.
So first I want to say, I mean
this has been an amazing day.
I hope everyone has enjoyed
themselves at DPLA Fest.
And it's not lost on
me the fest idea.
You know, this is supposed
to be a celebration.
It's supposed to be fun, you know.
This is really a celebration
of our cultural heritage.
And to me it's just
been an absolute honor,
and I'm very grateful to be here.
And I've been thinking
about that through the day.
And to be with so many people
who care so passionately
about getting this
information out to the world.
You know, it's our
country's history.
And this is our America
at its best to me.
It's not about hate or
exclusion, you know.
It's about how do we
include people in this?
How do we tell these stories?
And so I just want to acknowledge
that, that that's kind of the place
where a lot of us come to this from.
And it's great to be
with everyone here.
So, I just wanted to start
with that, a little of it.
And while we're not there yet,
we've got a lot of work to do.
This is what we want to talk about.
And on this panel particularly,
looking at one example.
We'll show you a little
bit about that.
I'm not going into huge
depth but really talk
about the collaboration behind
it and how DPLA and these kind
of changing the way
that we work together.
This life after the web or life on
the web is really opening the door
to collaborative working
environments
that we wouldn't have even
foreseen 25 years ago or so.
And how we take advantage
of those opportunities.
So, with that, before I say that
I want to talk just a little bit
about this panel, and everybody
will introduce themselves.
But when I first started
working in cultural heritage,
about eight years ago or
so, and when I say working
with cultural heritage,
working in cultural,
that means screen scraping,
downloading, stealing,
any other way I can get my
hands on cultural heritage data.
And I started to find
that libraries, archives
and museums were full of
radical ideas and radical people
who really wanted to make
this work accessible.
Even though I felt like I might
have been doing something,
you know, illegal or something.
Which it turns out I wasn't, okay.
Just so everyone knows.
One of the first things
that happened to me
when I started realizing that we
were working in bigger collections,
I came to Washington on vacation,
and Ed Summers was like hey,
you've got to meet
with Helena Zinkham.
And I felt like I'm going
to the principal's office.
Like I'm in serious trouble now.
We were at the time
working with Civil War data,
and I went and I met her.
And I kind of explained what we
were doing, taking all this data,
linked open data, how it
might be useful, etcetera.
And she looked at me, as she does,
kind of skeptically, and said,
well why aren't you
using this data set?
Right when I thought I was
going to get in trouble
for taking all these
other data sets.
She started throwing
more data sets at me.
And that's when I realized that
this was something that's really
gaining momentum.
This is a global movement
where we're trying
to encourage this kind of work.
And then a few years later
I was happy to meet Pam.
And she was like, well we've
got millions of things.
Why aren't you using
all of these things?
Let's get this out there.
So it keeps going.
So unfortunately, I just met
Dave a couple of months ago.
I don't even want to know
how much stuff he guys
at the Smithsonian for us to use.
Because at this point we've
got so much to work from.
So with that, that's my
introduction to these three.
But let's hear from you three.
What, you know, who you are and
what you do, and then we'll go
and we'll jump into some questions.
>> Helena Zinkham: So I'm Helena
Zinkham here today as Director
for Collections and Services
at the Library of Congress.
But my roots are in historical
photography, historical pictures.
>> Pamela Wright: Okay,
I'm Pam Wright.
I'm the Chief Innovation
Officer of the National Archives,
so I'm interested in
access to our holdings.
And in this century,
that means digital.
And so any way that we
can get where people are
and answer their questions,
give them our records,
let them see things
that they may never see,
look for in any other way coming
in the door, I want to do.
So that's what I'm into.
>> David McOwen: I'm the
Digital Media Developer
for Smithsonian Institution's
National Museum of American History.
That means I do a lot of web work.
It's a pretty small team, so it
means we do a lot of everything.
And it's really about getting
our content out to the people
who can't physically
come to the building
with a definite focus on education.
>> Jon Voss: Great.
I forgot to introduce
myself, I think.
>> Pamela Wright: Oh yeah.
>> Jon Voss: I'm Jon Voss,
the Strategic Partnership
Director at Historypin.
And one of the ways that we all
have gotten together on this,
thanks to the National Archive
just really kicking it off,
and you can see pictures behind us.
This is an app on the sort
of the National World War I app
that's become really, different ways
that we can access content
from World War I as we're
in the World War I centenary period,
which is 2014, really 2014 and 2020
when we look at how the social
impacts are from that time period.
And this project, just to kind
of give you a little framework,
is we have three real goals on this,
one of which is promoting discovery
and use of the collections.
And it really started with a focus
on the National Archives
moving picture images.
They have, you know,
this amazing collection
of World War I moving images
which are being preserved
and restored incredibly.
And you'll hear more
about that tomorrow.
Tomorrow morning there's a
panel with the Historypin
and National Archive teams talking
a little bit more about that.
The other goal is to
enrich these collections.
So what happens if people
are able to discover these
and then do more with them.
Now that's the next part of it.
And then finally to support the use
of this content in
local communities.
And once we started to do
this at the National Archives
and really apply this kind of
design thinking to this approach
and experiment with that,
we started to realize
that other institutions could
pretty easily join along with that.
And so that's what we've
opened the door to.
Now we've got National Archives,
Library of Congress, Smithsonian,
the World War One Centennial
Commission, World War I Museum.
This list could go on and on.
Digital Public Library of America,
the American Association of State
and Local History, Europeana
and Eurocleos [phonetic].
So it's become this
huge momentum gathering.
And we'll see a little bit
more again tomorrow morning,
what this might, I'm not really
going to go into the futures,
although I am going to flip
through a couple of these.
That it's about user
collections, tag-based enrichments,
and really seeing this, you
know, it's built for tablets.
Our dev team and Brenda will
talk more about this tomorrow,
really get into how this
helps bring digital photos
into a tactile environment,
which is exciting.
So that's kind of just gives
us a little bit of a context
about how we all started
working together.
And as a potential model for how
this could work across all kinds
of projects and how
it is already working
across all kinds of projects.
So with that, let's get started
with a couple of questions.
And I'm going to confess that I told
Helena what question I was going
to ask her.
So she's got, come on.
>> Helena Zinkham:
I've got pictures.
>> Jon Voss: She's got pictures.
So this is a leading question,
but, you know, because librarians,
they know what's going on.
So you have to be able to have them
prepared for what's going to happen.
So one of the, and this
is where it came up from.
We were talking about how this
app has this potential to be one
of the biggest national
collaborative projects
that you might have been
a part of in a long time.
And when we started
to get into that,
I mean this is someone
who's got amazing experience
in the library world.
And I'm really interested
for you to kind
of contextualize this a little bit,
for how collaboration has worked
in the library sector and
across archives and museums,
you know, in the last few years.
>> Helena Zinkham: So I have
a very short answer for Jon.
Key ingredient for
successful collaboration.
There we go.
Open access.
And by that I mean
free access and free
to reuse the content
of our collections.
That seems to be what
excites people the most,
but it's also the most
valuable, the most useful,
the most helpful to them.
And so when lots of different kinds
of institutions are getting ready
to collaborate, if the common
cause is built around access,
but not just the initial
use, the reuse,
the repackaging of the content.
That's where I think this World War
I mobile app will start taking us
in more and different directions.
I'm here today as Director
for Collections and Services.
I mentioned already, my roots are
in historical photo collections.
So as part of setting the stage, I'm
also here as your library historian.
A quick trip into the past
where in the early 1990s,
the Library of Congress
launched its commitment
to set the collections free.
And I'm speaking here of
the no known copyright
restriction collections.
I realize DPLA is broader than that.
But the days of American
memory when the idea is to,
Jon, okay, thank you Jon.
The idea was set the collections
free so that they would be available
to anyone, any time, anywhere.
You didn't have to make
that trip to Washington.
Library without walls.
That's what we called it.
>> Jon Voss: Yeah.
>> Helena Zinkham: But
of course I'm also here
to represent libraries in general.
And we're master collaborators
in the best sense of that word.
It's actually our life's blood.
If we don't share our resources,
we aren't going to survive.
We're that low funded.
Same is true of archives
and museums.
But this current slide
just is a reminder
that there's wonderful
collaborations around acquisitions,
who's going to collect what.
Cooperative cataloging,
shared storage facilities,
and the wonderful of
intra-library loan.
You take that, I want to step
back in history just one more time
with National Union Catalogs.
How many of you have heard
of that phrase before?
Oh a pretty good showing of hands.
>> Wow.
>> Helena Zinkham: So the photo
on the left, that's a picture
of card catalog distribution
in the Library of Congress.
It's a room in the Jefferson
Building, and from the floor
to the ceiling, those
are trays of cards.
And staff of, what do you think,
100 people, picking out the cards
and mailing them to other libraries.
How's that for sharing?
>> Jon Voss: That's amazing.
>> Helena Zinkham: Well eventually
from cards, print those citations
into great tall green volumes.
Today, and I think this is the
University of San Francisco,
we just make Christmas trees out of
the original National Union Catalog.
Definitely an out-motive
form of communication.
But the dream is alive.
In fact, heavily pursued.
Whether it's American
memory, American Archive
of Public Broadcasting, historical
American Building survey,
wonderful grant projects that
let people pool their resources
into shared spaces
so that it's easier
to find what we all have together.
Build something better
than one alone.
Among the mega collaborations,
there will, of course,
be the Digital Public
Library of America.
There's HathiTrust, Archive Grid,
Biodiversity Heritage Library,
Europeana, World Cap, how could I
forget, the current Union Catalog.
But I did want to spend just
a few moments on Flickr,
because I think more key ingredients
will kick out from that, Jon.
>> Jon Voss: Yeah.
>> Helena Zinkham: So
in 2007 the Library
of Congress called Flickr up.
We'd sent them some emails,
and they didn't reply.
So we tried the old-fashioned
telephone.
Fortunately George Oats
[phonetic] answered.
And she actually had
a grander vision
and created the Flickr commons.
In other words, rather than just
lots of different libraries,
archives and museums
having separate collections,
poured into the same space.
Of course it's pictures.
But what's special about it?
You're launching the
collections into a place
where people are looking
for pictures anyway.
And that means they're going to trip
across them even if they never knew
to look for them in the first place.
So it's mega access in my book.
But it's also an incredibly
simple framework.
It's low cost, multilingual,
no metadata standard beyond a
unique ID number, maybe a title.
It let people interact with the user
community however they wanted to.
And great creativity
has been released.
I wanted to encourage you
especially to take a look
at the National Library of Ireland.
They post maybe two,
three photos a week.
They get between 10 and 30
comments on every picture.
And it's substantive.
Information, context.
For the Library of Congress
we've updated 9,000 pictures.
We pull them back into our source
catalog and redistribute right back
out to the World War I
Act, to give one example.
So to wrap up this like launch pad
for what makes collaboration
work, what did I start with.
Open access.
Free to use and reuse,
a phrase I borrowed
from my boss who's here today.
I will acknowledge that.
But long standing success in
sharing and pooling resources.
Maybe we're getting too many
places to share our resources.
That might become a
hurdle we can talk about.
But otherwise, I hope I've set
the scene for success is more
than possible, success is essential
and happening all around us.
>> Jon Voss: Great.
I think it's interesting
when you talk about Flickr.
And we talked about that a
little bit the other day.
And just this idea that you had,
a really lightweight team trying
to do something very
simple by getting it out.
And it gives you a way to
connect directly with community
or build community, as
you mentioned in Ireland.
>> Helena Zinkham: Exactly.
>> Jon Voss: And that's a
big piece of it, you know,
I thought about that as I was lost
in the tunnels beyond, you know,
underneath the buildings
here, like how much you can do
by just getting a few
things out there.
>> Helena Zinkham: We frankly
worried about talking to you today.
We're three great big
federal institutions.
We must look richer
than [inaudible].
But the truth is, we
want collaborations
where small institutions, as
well as large, can participate.
And Flickr was a great
example in that.
>> Jon Voss: Great.
So Pam, to turn to you
on this a little bit.
The National Archives obviously
key to making this app happen.
And part of a much bigger
vision for what you're doing
at the National Archives when
you talk about sharing content
on almost unimaginable levels.
Tell us a little bit particularly
how this content was selected
and why this is an
important piece of content.
But how this also is an example
for future work that might happen
from National Archives
and other things,
other ways that you're doing work
from the Archives' perspective.
>> Pamela Wright: Great.
Thank you.
So the digitization process
at the National Archives
is a huge focus for us.
And we have 12 billion textual
pages of records and millions of,
hundreds of millions of
photographs and film.
We've just got a lot to do.
In our strategic plan,
under make access happen,
you will see that we are
going to digitize everything.
That is the moon shot that
the archivist set out for us,
and something that
it seems impossible.
But just by saying that,
it changes the mindset
and starts helping change the
culture of our agency to think
in this century for
something to be accessible.
What does that mean?
And it means digital for us.
And so in moving into
that digital world,
we developed a digitization
strategy.
And in that strategy we
thought about the different ways
that we want to get
digitization done.
But we also then opened it up to the
public and said, what do you want?
How should we prioritize the
digitization that we're going to do?
And so we have a matrix
of decision-making
for what we prioritize
for digitization.
And we're doing everything we can to
walk down that list and, you know,
make sure that we make
in a digital way,
the records accessible
to the public.
So that's what, that's kind of that
larger vision where this sits in.
So it's great to make it
available in our catalog.
But our catalog has so much.
I see that as kind of
the ocean of our records.
Right now we have 10
million descriptions
in our catalog, just descriptions.
Another 9.7 million digital objects.
We have a whopping 220 million
ready to come in as we scale
up the catalog over the
next couple of years.
So just the size is
overwhelming for people.
And what I really like about this
project and what we're working
on together is, because
we could all easily,
any one of us could overwhelm
this app pretty quickly.
It's not comprehensive in
thinking in new ways Brenda
on your staff talked to our staff
about paths into our records.
And that path finding is something
that we really, I think we thought
of before, but this idea that
you don't have everything.
You can have a slice to get in.
I love that idea.
>> Jon Voss: And I've had the
great opportunity and privilege
in our team to really dig into the
archives there a little bit with.
I mean just, I made some, the best
of the country in terms of curators,
in terms of preservationists.
People who know this stuff so well.
And part of that, part of what
you're working on with all
of this is how do you
open the doors to people?
You know, there's a
research room obviously,
and it's used in certain ways.
But how are you proactively
looking at getting the public
into those spaces in new ways?
I mean there's some
things in the works?
>> Pamela Wright: Well we have the
innovation Hub that's a brand new.
>> Jon Voss: It's brand new.
>> Pamela Wright: Yeah.
So at Archives One here downtown,
and I think tomorrow there's
a hack-a-thon in there.
We found a room on the first floor
and decided to kind of open it
up as a space for the public
and staff to work together
on innovation initiatives and
projects that we're working on.
So yeah, so you will get
to see that tomorrow,
and we welcome you over there.
What we're really doing
in a part of the Hub,
one of the projects is
citizen archivist digitization.
So if you're a researcher
at the National Archives,
and you agree to give us a copy
of anything that you're scanning,
we'll make sure to put your name in
the catalog, along with the scan.
So it's contributed by
citizen archivist Jon Voss.
And it goes up in our catalog.
This idea of opening up our catalog
and really we're calling it a
social catalog, making it open
so that the public can
contribute, not just consume,
is really important to us.
>> Jon Voss: Yeah, that's great.
It's, I mean it kind of reminds
me we talked a little bit
about this room setup, right.
Like when we talked
about this panel.
It's like it's just going to
be an informal discussion,
and Helena was like, they
do ballets on this stage.
So like 50 years ago
or 100 years ago
when these room were being built,
that's kind of indicative
of the model, right.
>> Pamela Wright: Exactly.
>> Jon Voss: Like wisdom would
be imparted from this place.
And I think we're now looking at,
and I think the Hub
is a great example.
Like the tables move, the
chairs move, the white boards.
It's a really exciting space.
We're actually building
things differently now.
So I think that's a telling
sign of where we're going.
So Dave, I want to talk to
you a little about, you know,
we talked about The Smithsonian
as a thing, but you know very well
and you've made clear that
it's actually a large number
of institutions who are already
finding ways to work together
within that, both internally
and externally.
So what have you learned about
collaboration in that space,
in your environment there?
And how has that changed
even in recent years?
>> David McOwen: It's
changed entirely
over the last few years
that I've been there.
You know, The Smithsonian
is, there is the castle,
and there's an administrative unit.
There's central IT unit
that supports us wonderfully
when it comes to getting our
objects out into the web.
But it's, you know, I work for
the new media department in the,
you know, Office of Public
Engagement in American History.
So that's one museum.
There's 18 others.
There's a zoo.
There's nine research units.
That's The Smithsonian.
So you know, when we collaborate
externally, that's kind of the end
of a very lengthy internal
collaboration process just to get
to step one with other
people, which is great.
But it's, you know, it
does take a lot of effort.
And it's a little more
chaotic because, you know,
we have great support
from the general counsel
to make legal documents happen.
And we have support from the
castle to make connections.
But in this case, we decided, you
know, this is a really good idea.
We're American history.
We probably have the most
World War I stuff anyway.
So we'll be the trailblazers.
We'll go. We'll work
through the things.
We always work with
an idea internally
and in collaborative projects of
okay, how do we get this done.
But how do we do this
in a way that's going
to enable the people next
door to do it tomorrow
or next week or next year.
We've been pretty successful
with that across the board
with our digital platforms.
>> Jon Voss: Right.
>> David McOwen: But it really is.
And that's, aside from having
open data, which we're working on,
we're working towards that.
The other piece of it is really
having a reliable platform
that other people are going to
be able to use and is going to be
around for a little while.
Because it takes us a while to
kind of get spooled up on things.
And it's a lot of effort.
Even if it's, you know,
free information,
it's objects that we've
already published out.
The labels are written.
All of that stuff's done.
That still takes time.
It takes a, you know, a
staff member to sit down
and come up with the stories.
Come up with the paths.
Come up with the themes for things.
And that's not even
counting the objects
that aren't digitized yet, you know.
We did a project about the
Civil War, sesquicentennial.
Civil Rights anniversary.
And they were great, but they
were one off technology platforms.
And so they worked for the time,
and now we've kind of
put them over here.
And that doesn't help you kind of
build the momentum that you need,
you know, within The
Smithsonian, within any kind
of large organization where
you've got multiple pieces,
let alone being able to then turn
and, you know talk to other people
and say hey, we have this thing.
Do you want to come play and let's
build this and make it even better
and get our content out there?
>> Jon Voss: Right.
Great. So I also, I
want to make sure
if you have any questions,
please start jumping in.
Raise your hands.
I'll keep asking questions all day.
But if you have something, I want
you to be able to dig into it.
There you go.
>> Thanks very much.
So the three of you represent
three legacies [inaudible].
>> Helena Zinkham:
And actually Carol,
if you could give us one second.
Joe's bringing a mike down for you.
>> Oh, okay.
Thank you.
>> Helena Zinkham: Thanks Joe.
>> So I just mentioned
that, you know,
the three of you represent legacy
institutions tied to this country.
And I'd be interested to know,
what's the biggest thing holding
the three of you back individually
as institutions and holding
the three of you back
from working more collectively
and collaboratively?
Is it technology?
Is it funding?
Is it?
>> Jon Voss: Policy.
>> Policy.
>> Jon Voss: Good question.
Who wants to jump in on that?
>> Pamela Wright: I'll, so I
think that some of the things
that we're getting over, the hurdles
that we're getting
over is the culture.
And the institution, in
our institution anyway,
was it's collaborative, but
collaborative is kind of gravy.
And what we do and our mission,
we focus very internally
and do that work.
And I think one of my staff said,
it's no longer just what you
know, it's what you share.
And that idea
of now mission-critical work
actually happens collaboratively.
And that culture changing from,
we're going to just keep our head
down and not talk to anybody and
get our work done is changing.
So I think there's culture change
in it, and then just funding
for digitization is, you know,
it costs a lot to do it right.
So I think those two are big.
As we get to know each other more
and we get out of these meetings
and stuff, I feel like those, that
is becoming easier and easier.
It's just making sure that
we have leadership at the top
of our institutions that say
collaboration is important
and is critical to the mission.
>> Helena Zinkham: And I
have a different take on it.
So I don't actually, I agree with
Pam, those are the good hurdles.
But I also think we just
haven't done a good enough job
of showing how often and how
richly we do collaborate.
So for example, there
are the heritage months.
And the Library of Congress stepped
in, and we host that website.
And it must be at least ten
different federal agencies
that contribute their content and
their events to a single web space.
But we also collaborate
all the time on standards.
So the federal digitizing guidelines
initiative, but with web harvesting.
That's another great
example of collaboration.
I think that we have at times
taken turns, and that looks
as if we're not collaborating.
But in fact, we're just deciding
how to share the workload
and how to share the funding.
So I'd like to give
two more examples.
The National Endowment
for Humanities.
It's great.
The Library of Congress has
fantastic newspaper holdings.
But we're not the be-all
and end-all.
So in partnership with National
Endowment for Humanities we agreed
to take responsibility to be the
long-term preservation steward
and the access provider.
But it's 40 different states
throughout the country
and the territories
participating today.
And they've just crossed a milestone
of 10 million pages of newspapers.
Fantastic.
So despite what you read in the
newspapers from time to time,
the Library is alive and
well and very busily,
I mean the content is pouring in.
StoryCorps.
Can you imagine when he app mobile?
Terabytes, petabytes, weekly.
And we're keeping up.
American Archive of
Public Broadcasting.
So there too at a national level
will take this turn and go ahead
and collaborate with WGBH.
That's the incunabula of television,
right up to the present eventually.
They're going to provide the access
because of the rights constraints.
But we'll step in on
the preservation side.
So I think, if you can
help us understand how
to better publicize our work, that
would probably be a good thing.
Because there's a lot more
going on than what shows.
>> Jon Voss: Yeah, I think
that's a great point in terms
of how that's presented
to the public, you know.
And when there is so much going on,
how is it that you build this
sort of open environment?
You know, as you say.
And it's like, for me,
when I thought I was going
to the principal's office
when I first met you.
>> Helena Zinkham.
Welcome Jon.
It's a great idea.
>> Jon Voss: Yeah, come on in.
And it's about, kind of, and
it took somebody telling me
who to talk to for that to happen.
So that's a great, I think that
is a really important barrier
that we might look at.
How to overcome.
Do you have thoughts on this?
>> David McOwen: Yeah,
I mean, like I said,
The Smithsonian is a little more
compartmentalized between the units.
So we do collaborations
all the time.
It's generally one-on-one,
one-on-two.
When you're talking about
this level of collaboration,
which I think happens
less frequently, to me,
that basically comes for
us down to digitization
and getting the data
in an open format.
You know, four years ago you
couldn't go to one central website
to search Smithsonian's collections.
Now you can, 9.6 million objects.
That sounds awesome.
We have 138 million objects.
So we have a lot of work to do.
And for now, that's a closed system.
So I think the key
to unlock this door
to worldwide massive collaboration
is getting the data out there
and into the hands of
anybody who wants to use it.
>> Jon Voss: Anyone
else have something?
I just, also as a quick
follow-up to that.
Sometimes it's frustrating
to me because I think
of this as an open gov thing.
You know, we hear a
lot about open gov.
But we don't have that conversation
so much within cultural heritage.
And I think that's something
that we can leverage as well.
That there is a real remit
to have this out there
for the public and
for the public good.
And having that come
from the top down.
I think you're absolutely
right about this.
You know, there needs
to be a culture
of this being a critical
part of what we're doing.
So. Other questions for this crew?
>> David McOwen: Come on now.
>> Helen Zinkham: It is
the end of [Inaudible].
>> Jon Voss: Alright, I'll ask
questions to these three all day.
Believe me, this is so.
Let's see.
So one of the things that is often
to me when we work on these kinds
of projects, I find that the
technical barriers tend to be more,
we can overcome those a lot easier
than the policy barriers
or the legal barriers.
Now with this project, for instance,
it's been pretty straightforward.
Marcus has been a huge
person through, you know,
like having a team that says
here's a very simple agreement
of how we're going to
cooperate together.
And it's been amazing to see the
legal counsels on both teams,
or all teams make that happen.
But what are, how is that
played out for you on this
or for other projects, and how
can you foresee streamlining
that in the future?
I mean we talk about the culture,
but let's talk a little bit more
about the logistical elements.
You know, what if you've
got an enthusiast out there
that says I've got a great idea
for a World War II project.
I'm going to need these
things to do these things.
How might that happen in
the future going forward?
You know, how do we
facilitate those things?
>> Helen Zinkham: So
do you mean the degree
to which we'd be the tool builders.
But then anyone could come and
bring their project or participate?
>> Jon Voss: Maybe not
even the tool builders.
You know, I think about when we
started the Civil War data project,
right?
It was, your take was, and
this maybe is also an evolution
of the tools over the time.
That was ten years ago you
said, we have an OEI PMH server.
You can download all this stuff.
Make sure you look at
what the content looks
like as well, you know.
Now there's APIs, National
Archives has an API.
Smithsonian, yours is a
little bit more unlocked.
>> David McOwen: It's,
we're working towards it.
>> Jon Voss: Okay.
>> David McOwen: It is a priority
that our previous secretary,
digitization was, you
know, a priority,
that hasn't discontinued yet.
>> Jon Voss: Right.
>> David McOwen: But yeah
it's, we're working towards it.
A lot of that is resources.
A lot of that is making
that a priority
to build something that's going
to work for us and for the public.
>> Jon Voss: Well in your case,
you see that for internal
use first probably, right.
Like how is this data going
to be used accessible
within the institutions?
But then taking that a step further.
>> David McOwen: Yeah, I mean,
there's so many layers as far as,
you know, whenever
we publish an object,
it goes through a lengthy
process of, you know,
do we actually own this object.
Can we prove that we
own this object?
Are there any rights that
we didn't know about?
Along with the curatorial
process and just kind
of the collections process of making
sure all the details are right.
So that slows us down a lot.
>> Jon Voss: Yeah.
>> Helena Zinkham: So
maybe you're also asking
about user contributed content.
One of the great things David
that occurs to me, a gift I've had
because of working with pictures,
they also come so scantily clad
with metadata, we've been dependent
on other people telling us
what's going on in pictures
for an awfully long time.
So the idea that it has to be
finished and polished, it's never,
never really been in play.
We seek. We craved.
Tell us more about.
So I hope I didn't misstep here.
But user contributed content,
programs like the Veterans
History Project.
You're actively putting out a call.
If you know a veteran,
please make an interview.
And you can send that to
the Library of Congress.
There's a certain degree
of standard.
Could the sound file
be in this format?
We'd love to have a mobile app.
I know it isn't modern
enough at this point.
Fifteen years in.
But that's a very clear, it's a
collection acquisition strategy.
And you put out a call for
help and open the doors.
The firehouse people have
surfaced recently and said,
we've gathered all this
amazing information.
Can't you take care of it for us?
>> Jon Voss: Oh, interesting.
>> Helena Zinkham: So it's
not something we anticipated,
but it's certainly
something we can talk about.
>> Jon Voss: Right.
Great. Pam, any thoughts.
>> Pamela Wright: So I'm just
thinking about, you know,
ten years ago when we did MOUs
with like ancestry when we started.
It was very scary, and
there were, you know,
it was long discussions,
lots of meetings.
It took a long time to get to that.
Because of that work, because
of all the work that's happened
in the past, we know are
really comfortable with MOUs,
how they work, what
are we going to do.
And I feel like we've got a
good relationship and kind
of track record with
our legal counsel.
So now these MOUs are
much easier to do.
I think it's easier to
collaborate than it ever was before.
>> Jon Voss: Yeah it's like there's
a little bit of a transition to,
you know, you used to be really CYA.
Make sure we don't get
burned on anything.
And really long things.
But it's kind of converted
to how can we make sure
that this stuff is getting out.
And that speaks to that
cultural change too.
>> Pamela Wright: And the
question of risk changes.
>> Jon Voss: That's right.
>> Pamela Wright: The risk isn't
how we're going to get burned
but what if we don't participate.
What if we aren't out there.
And I think that is
so exciting to see.
>> Helena Zinkham: So social
media probably helped with that.
>> Pamela Wright.
Yeah.
>> Helena Zinkham: I'm going
to see if we can't hear
from the audience on this one.
What are your hurdles?
Is it policy?
Is it legal?
>> Jon Voss: Yeah.
>> I actually have a.
>> Helena Zinkham: Four
different questions.
>> It really follows
directly along the line
of what you've been
discussing so far.
And you've touched on
it kind of tangentially.
But, how do you reconcile
different prioritization within each
of your entities when it comes
time to doing things together?
In other words, one of the things I
think we discover often is something
that seems a priority to us
may not be the same level
of priority to a partner.
And yet we need resources from that
partner to do the collaboration.
So, and granted your point about
that experience of having done this
and gone through the legal
hurdles and that kind
of stuff is a major
streamlining thing.
But it does seem to me
that reconciling priorities
between entities which may have at
a very broad level a common mission,
but specifically may have other
things that each is trying to get
down over a short period of time,
has to represent some complications.
How do you work through it?
>> Helena Zinkham: So in,
we look for common cause.
Sometimes it's bottom up.
So we each probably
have strategic plans.
I know NARA does, Library of
Congress just published its own.
We find the line that
touches on digitization.
The Library of Congress isn't going
to say, well digitize everything.
Why? Because we have a lot of
published under copyright material.
We don't want to scare our
user community entirely.
So ours would say,
maximize digitizing,
prioritized to the rights
free, the rights cleared.
But when it was World War I time,
and back to my taking turns part,
we could all see the
centennial coming.
It was The Smithsonian
who stepped in.
They convened this huge
two-day conference.
Got everybody in [inaudible]
together and sort of took a poll.
What are you thinking about?
What's going to happen?
How's it turning out?
And there've been follow-up
meetings.
So there's communication.
We don't have to have
necessarily a shared exhibition,
but we can make sure that we
don't step on top of each other.
Who's going to scan which
of their collections?
So NARA's gone big time into your
wonderful movies for World War I.
The Library of Congress
also has movies.
These are government
military training films.
Ours comes perhaps more
from private sector.
It may be commercial producers.
I guess I'm trying to say
that the parts fit together.
Could we do more things together?
Maybe that's part of the louder
voice, the better megaphone.
But I don't too often feel like
people are arriving on the doorstep
and saying, I've got a great idea.
You need to buy this meat, cook
that dinner and serve it back to me.
It is a little friendlier than that.
>> David McOwen: Yeah, and I'll say,
nobody has as much
money as they want to.
So you're already,
hopefully, used to the idea
of strategically selecting
the objects or the materials
that you're going to focus on.
Hopefully centered around some kind
of story or narrative or something
that has multiple levels of entry.
So I think everyone's doing that.
So if you sit down and say okay,
what story are you telling?
Well we're not going
to tell that story.
The posters.
We have tons of World War I posters.
Well, they have all the posters.
So we don't need to tell that story.
Now we do have the original
artwork for the Uncle Sam poster.
So we're going to prioritize
that because
that tells a different story, a
unique story that only we can tell.
And so we try to focus on those.
And I think if everyone does the
same thing and then realizes,
oh hey, let's a conversation.
We really think this is important.
We're like, oh we think
that's important too.
Alright, let's combine.
So I don't think it's as foreign
as it used to be certainly.
>> Jon Voss: So I want to close on
one last question for each of you.
We're getting to the end here.
Is there anything, anyone else?
Just to leave it on a
very optimistic note.
For the dream of what
the future of these kinds
of collaborations look like.
You get whatever you wanted.
You could start over.
You would not have all the
infrastructure [inaudible].
What would that look
like for you five years
from now, ten years from now?
What might it look like anyway?
>> David McOwen: I'll go first.
>> Jon Voss: Go ahead.
>> David McOwen: Open
data, open data, open data.
I want all of our data, and
I want it in your hands.
I do think that, especially as we
kind of migrate this cultural shift
into a digital world
that authenticity
and reliability is going
to remain an issue.
So there's always going
to be a place, I think,
for cultural institutions
to curate their information.
That is not mutually exclusive
from everyone else curating
your information as well.
And to me, the most exciting
part of that is kind of get
into semantic data, the connections
that you're going to make
between our data and between our
data and other people's data.
That's fantastic.
That's a beautiful
thing to consider.
I love that Cooper Hewitt, when
they did their collection search,
you can search by color.
Which makes sense for
them, their design museum.
I want to do that for our
stuff, because that's fun.
It's interesting.
[ Inaudible ]
You know, so, you know, shake up the
Yahtzee cup and see what falls out.
And I think the public and
cultural institutions and libraries,
they enjoy that because they can,
you know, play with your objects.
And I think we have a lot
to learn from that as well.
Things that we will never, ever
come to if we just sit in our kind
of one-way conversations.
As interactive as we
try to make things,
it's still predominantly
a one-way conversation.
So I can't wait for that.
I think it's going to be amazing.
>> Jon Voss: Awesome.
>> Helena Zinkham: Go ahead.
>> Pamela Wright: Okay.
So, we have talked about this
a lot at the National Archives.
And one of the, I mean there's
lots of ways to answer this.
But just one of the ways that comes
to me if you're asking this is,
one of my staff said, wouldn't it be
excellent if you didn't have to know
which of the institutions you
had to go to to ask a question.
Could you just ask a question,
and they kind of help you?
And we learned from a
product that we have
within the National Archives called
the internal collaboration network.
It's on the Jive platform, and
it's a way to share documents
and talk across the agency.
And that same platform is what Apple
uses when your phone dies and you go
to an Apple forum and
say hey, what do I do.
And either an export from
Apple, or more likely somebody
from the community that knows how
to do it, will answer your question.
And so we have been looking
at using that platform,
and we call it history hub, and
what we're just in pilot now,
but what we'd really like to do is
see if we could work with Library
of Congress and Smithsonian so that
somebody could come to that platform
and say hey, I'm look
for sand borne maps.
I know you guys have some.
I know we have some.
We have expertise in
different areas like that.
It would be really cool
to work collaboratively
so that the public
could get their answer
and not have to know where we are.
So that's just one example.
>> Jon Voss: Yeah great.
>> Helena Zinkham: So I want all
the tools seamlessly available
Geospatial hosting environment,
transcription services.
Lots of user contributing content.
Lots of interaction.
Lots more money.
But I think I'm also
just open to change.
Bring it on.
>> Jon Voss: Alright.
>> Helena Zinkham: We didn't
anticipate the internet.
We didn't anticipate the web.
But I found the so on and so forth.
So staying flexible, staying open.
I'm ready.
>> Jon Voss: Awesome.
Well thank you.
You know it's been an absolute
honor for me to work with you three,
to work with a lot
of the people here.
And for people watching online
and in the future I can
just say, dream big.
You know, talk to these people.
Reach out to folks and
do things together.
There's just so much
opportunity here.
So thanks, and look forward to
working with you all in the future.
Thank you very much.
>> Helena Zinkham: Thanks Jon.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.